♪
>> Mark: HAVE YOU GOT HALF A
MILLION BUCKS TO SPARE FOR A
PAINTING POSITION GO OVER YOUR
MAN TELL PIECE?
THERE ARE BARGAINS GALORE TO BE
HAD OUT THERE.
THIS 1600 PORTRAIT OF THE
LONGEST RAINING MAGNIFICENT
RECENTLY SOLD FOR UNDER 500
GRAND AT SOUTH BUYS IN LONDON.
THAT GUY CERTAINLY KNOWS HOW TO
DO NOSES.
OR FOR HALF A MILL PICKED UP
THIS LORENZO PAINTING OF SAINT
CATHERINE OF ALEXANDRIA WITH THE
SIX VIRTUES AND CHRIST THE
REDEEMER ABOVE.
IF YOUR FEYESS INCLINE ELSEWHERE
FOR 500 Gs COULD HAVE GOT THIS
DAGA ORRIN WAR OR PICASSO BUT
PROBABLY THINKING FOR HALF A
MILLION GREEN BACKS I DON'T WANT
SOME LOUSY PICASSO OR POST
IMPRESSIONIST GIRL WITH A DRESS
SLIDING OFF HER BOSOM OR DOWNER
OLD DUDE HUNG UP ON SAINTS.
I'M LOOKING FOR A REAL BANG FOR
MY BUCK.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN FOR A MERE
$500,000, YOU CAN NOW BUY A
GENUINE, WAIT FOR IT, A GENUINE
HUNTER BIDEN.
IF YOU ARE WONDERING WHAT THAT
IS?
IT'S THE SURVIVING STRIP OF
HUNTER'S TY I DO SHIRT FROM HIS
SEVENTH BIRTHDAY PARTY IN 1977
NEXT TO SOME VALVE LIEN 10 W 30
HE HUFFED OUT OF HIS RENTAL CAR
AND BLEW THROUGH ART PIPE.
YES, USUALLY YOU HAVE TO BE DEAD
TO FETCH HALF A MILLION.
HUNTER IS NOT DEAD.
IS HE JUST SLEEPING IT OFF.
HE HAS ONLY BEEN A PROFESSIONAL
PAINTER SINCE, OH, LET ME SEE
NOW AROUND ABOUT LUNCHTIME ON
JANUARY THE 20TH.
BEFORE THEN, HIS ART FETCHED A
1.79 FROM THE LAST DAY GRAB BAG
TABLE RUMMAGE SALE.
SINCE 20TH HE HAS CAUGHT ONE
PICASSO AND LEONARD DOUGH AT HIS
HEELS.
THE ART CRITIC REACTED TO THIS
MASTER PIECE BY SAYING OH MY GOD
THAT LOOKS LIKE COVID.
HE IS NOT WRONG.
HERE'S THE CORONAVIRUS, AND HERE
IS HUNTER'S VERSION.
THE CORONAVIRUS STUCK ON THE END
OF HIS CRACK PIPE.
BUT HUNTER'S COVID PAINTING IS
AN ART WORLD SUPER SPREADER
INFECTING EVERYONE IN SIGHT.
DO YOU REMEMBER A COUPLE YEARS
BACK WHEN IMPRESSIONABLE
CATHOLIC OLIGARCHS AND SAUDI
PRINCES WERE MYSTERIOUSLY EAGER
TO PAY THE CLINTON FOUNDATION
2 MILLION BUCKS FOR A SPEECH BY
CHELSEA ON DIARRHEA IN AFRICA?
WELL HUNTER'S HALF MILLION
DOLLARS CORONA ESCAPE IS THE
DIARRHEA SPEECH OF TEMPORARY
ART.
DO YOU HAVE A REUBENS, SELL THEM
ALL.
DON'T BOTHER SELLING THEM.
GIVE THEM TO UNDOCUMENTED NANNY,
SHE'LL WILL BE ABLE TO GET A
COUPLE OF BUCKS FOR THE FRAME.
THE PEERLESS ART CRITIC RAIMONDO
ARROYO.
HE DOESN'T KNOW MUCH ABOUT ART
BUT HE KNOWS WHAT HE DOESN'T
LIKE.
WHAT DO YOU FEEL ABOUT
MYSTERIOUS EXPLOSION IN HUNTER
BIDEN'S ART PRICES?
>> MARK, YOU NAILED IT.
THE CLINTON FOUNDATION THAT WAS
THEIR PROXY TO GET INFLUENCE AND
FAVORS.
THE BIDEN FAMILY HAS HUNTER'S
ART SALE.
BUT THE PROBLEMATIC THING IS
HERE YOU HAVE THE WHITE HOUSE
THAT HAS COME OUT WITH IT OWN
ETHICAL PROTOCOL.
THEY SAY, LOOK, NIBBING HUNTER'S
ART WILL BE KEPT ANONYMOUS.
NO ONE WILL KNOW SO, THEREFORE
THAT WILL ABSOLVE US OF ANY
INFLUENCE PEDDLING, THE TRUTH
HERE YOU ARE RELYING ON THE GUY
AT THE GALLERY SELLING HUNTER'S
ART, THAT'S THE ETHICAL
BENCHMARK.
THAT'S THE FIRE WALL.
I'M NOT ALL THAT CONFIDENT THAT
HE WON'T TELL HUNTER OR WHAT'S
TO STOP, MARK, SOMEBODY
SAUNTERING UP TO JOE OR JILL
BIDEN OR A MEMBER OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND SAYING, YOU
KNOW, I PAID $2 MILLION FOR THE
HUNTER'S BABY MOMMA COLLECTION.
I EXPECT A LITTLE ACCESS THIS
AFTERNOON.
I MEAN THERE IS VERY WORRISOME
OR SHOULD BE.
THIS SOUNDS LIKE THE SAME HUNTER
BIDEN WITHOUT THE FREQUENT FLIER
MILE.
>> Mark: BETTER REACT THAN THE
CLINTON ADMINISTRATION AS YOU
EXPLAIN NO NEED FOR THE RELEVANT
OLIGARCH WHO DECIDES HE IS GOING
TO BE AN ART COLLECTOR.
HIS NAME EVER TO EMERGE, IS
THERE?
>> NO, NO.
AND I LOVE THESE ART CRITICS WHO
ARE SAYING WELL, THIS IS A
LITTLE BIT LIKE KURT COBAIN'S
SWEATER.
EVERYONE WILL WANT TO OWN THIS
BECAUSE OF ITS HISTORIC VALUE.
WAIT A MINUTE, KURT COBAIN WAS A
POP CULTURE ICON.
HUNTER BIDEN, GOD BLESS HIM, HIS
ONLY ACCOMPLISHMENT IS BEING JOE
BIDEN'S SON, RUNNING UP A TAB AT
STRIP CLUBS AND SOME DIAMOND
STATUS POINTS AT THE REHAB
CLINIC.
LET'S BE HONEST, WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE ART AS YOU SHOWED
EARLIER, MARK, IT'S NOT GEORGEER
IS ROT.
THIS LOOKS LIKE RORSCHACH
SPLATTER OR AS YOU SAID COVID
UNDER THE GLASS.
IT'S NOT EDIFYING.
>> Mark: NO, I THINK SOMEONE
CALLED IT BAD HOTEL ART.
AND I CERTAINLY AM NEVER GOING
TO CHECK IN AT ANY HOTEL THAT IS
HANGING HUNTER BIDEN IN THE
LOBBY.
THANK YOU FOR THAT RAIMONDO, WE
RAYMOND WE WILL SEE YOU WITH
LAURA TONIGHT OR AS THE WEEK
GOES ON.